with the release of the Android M
developer preview SDK developers are
jumping in to make sure their apps are
up to date with changes in the framework
I'm vitac alle-kiski and i'll show you
how new features that we're introducing
an android studio 1.3 can help you with
the transition the single biggest change
in Android M is the overhaul of the
permission system from now on before
using certain api's you need to make
sure your app asks for the necessary
permissions during runtime but given a
large code base how do you know which
methods actually required this special
handling an android studio 1.3 we're
adding al intro that the text methods
marked with the new requires permission
sanitation from the support library the
editor will now highlight code that
users permissions which are missing from
your android manifest moreover if it
detects you haven't performed the
necessary runtime check in your code it
will suggest a quick fix static code
analysis like this can help you catch
common programming mistakes even before
you run your app on the device or
emulator the requires permission
annotation is actually defined in the
support library and works in tandem with
a lint checker in Android studio let's
go through some other annotations that
you will find in the latest release
threading annotations guard you against
calling methods on the wrong thread
let's say you're doing some background
processing like in this async task
example because the async task methods
are already properly annotated the IDE
will alert you if you try changing the
right from here by calling methods on
the textview instance on the other hand
android studio knows it's safe to invoke
UI code in unposted xecutor as it is
marked with the main thread annotation
up next the size and range annotations
for integers and floats they can be used
for controlling the length of your
arrays and strings or making sure a
number is in a specified range they're
especially handy for annotating method
parameters so that the color can
immediately know what kind of values are
expected if you want to study those in
more detail as well as learn about other
annotations like check result and call
super click through to the documentation
here remember that you don't have to
rely on the annotation
that we've included in the android
framework you are free to add them to
your own methods and classes so that
anyone using your code will benefit from
the additional checks performed by
Android studio speaking of sharing code
android studio 1.3 introduces support
for hiding resources in library modules
perhaps it's easiest to demonstrate on
an example here's what used to happen
when you try to use auto completion in
the layout file when you have app compat
in your dependencies and here is the
same operation using the newest versions
of both studio and the support library
most of the resources we see on the left
are used internally by the creators of
the library and were never meant to be
available for third-party developers not
only do they introduce clutter and
pollute your projects namespace things
might also break with any update if you
decide to use them in your layouts to
define which resources should be visible
for users of your library simply put a
public XML file in your values folder
provide an entry containing the type and
name of each resource you want to set us
public this information will also be
bundled and available to Android studio
if you decide to distribute your library
in a AR format with the release of 1.3
we're bringing more tools that were
previously available as external
applications into Android studio you can
now open your object allocation trace
files and the new allocation tracker
which shows you a visual overview of
where allocations happen in your code
and gives you a way to dig right into
the data another memory inspection tool
that is now available right in the IDE
is the heap dump viewer for opening age
profiles it gives you access to the
reference tree of any object in memory
as well as a property inspector similar
to the variable debugger window use it
to examine the state of objects at the
moment when the memory snapshot was
taken and to track down any rogue
references that prevent them from being
garbage collected by the way we've also
added small improvements and the
traditional debugger interface from now
on when you inspect a variable that
holds a resource identifier you can
easily see the human readable name
instead by switching to the Android
typed in GT review
there are many more new features in
Android studio 1.3 integration with the
data binding library ending developer
services from the product structure
dialog live code templates and finally a
preview of the upcoming C C++ editing
and NDK support in the IDE so upgrade
android studio now and as always please
report any bugs in our Google+ community
here thanks